Hola Bienvenidos a una semana en el
mundo del programa de France 24 en el
que los periodistas son los invitados y
con ellos conversamos de una manera más
distensionada sobre algunos de los temas
más destacados de la semana para
conversar sobre la selección de temas
que tenemos para este programa hemos
invitado a Ilia cedeño ella es editora
de la sección global del periódico
excelsior ella se conecta desde la
Ciudad de México illiam bienvenida
Gracias por estar con nosotros y qué tal
termina usted su semana bienvenida
Muchas gracias Santiago Gracias a todos
los que nos escuchan Pues sí una semana
muy agitada en materia periodística
acompañarnos también ustedes con sus
opiniones y sus comentarios también las
preguntas son bienvenidas a través de
nuestras redes sociales arroba franz24
guión bajo ese arroba santilogo que es
mi cuenta personal nuestro nuestra
etiqueta es numeral una semana en el
mundo f24 Más adelante se va a
incorporar a este programa otra invitada
que tenemos para hablar de los
diferentes temas y sumarse a esta
conversación vamos a empezar entonces
con ilian hablando de México en donde
tuvo lugar a lo largo de esta semana
pues una noticia un tanto lamentable y
también un poco controvertida por
decirlo así y tiene que ver con ese
incendio en un centro de detención de
migrantes en Ciudad Juárez en Chihuahua
en el estado de Chihuahua el resultado
39 personas fallecidas y cerca de 30 más
heridas Y hospitalizadas lamentablemente
este grupo de personas no pudieron
evacuar el lugar en el que se
encontraban cuando las llamas aumentaron
a raíz de un incendio que ellos mismos
los provocaron como una forma de
protesta al ser informados de su
inminente deportación las críticas han
caído sobre las autoridades mexicanas
hay mucha presión sobre el presidente
Andrés Manuel López Obrador este hecho
también dejan evidencia las condiciones
a las que son sometidos los migrantes en
México que recordemos es un tercer país
en este proceso migratorio entre el país
de origen y el país de destino México es
un país que está tratando de frenar un
poco ser un poco colchón en este proceso
migratorio illiam pues lamentable estos
hechos que han tenido lugar en México
hay muchísima presión sobre las
autoridades y muchísima presión sobre el
presidente Andrés Manuel López Obrador
Cómo se desarrolló este tema a lo largo
de la semana allí en México
Sí pues Se generó como bien dice
Santiago un debate muy fuerte primero
por la parte ciudadana luego también por
la parte política como bien mencionas
incluye ahí un debate acerca de los
derechos que se violentaron porque en
efecto estaban encerrados los migrantes
de entrada es no es un refugio como lo
ha calificado el presidente Andrés
Manuel López Obrador y algunos de su
bancada política porque de ser un
refugio en las condiciones serían otras
estaban en un centro de detención a la
hora de que se desata esta protesta
cuando los migrantes incendian las
colchonetas los policías y está
documentado hay videos que lo que lo
documentan los dejan encerrados salen de
ahí los dejan encerrados de ahí viene el
cuestionamiento es un accidente fue el
estado fueron las autoridades se dio
esto por una protesta Pero quién es
responsable de esas treinta y nueve
muertes ya hay detenidos ya hubo
personas detenidas ahorita lo están
investigando de acuerdo con con las
autoridades se va a investigar como un
homicidio ya implicados ya
investigaciones Pero sigue sin haber una
un dedo que apunte directamente a las
omisiones que hubo en este proceso como
comentas en materia migratoria hay una
crisis que enfrentamos desde hace años
en los países en principalmente México y
Estados Unidos que México ya dejó de ser
un país de tránsito en México se han
quedado muchísimos migrantes el gobierno
también ha cedido en esta parte y en un
programa acordado también de aceptar a
varios de ellos no a miles de ellos pero
en este proceso los que pasan en estos
en algunos casos refugios o aquí un
centro de detención porque es lo que es
del Instituto Nacional de Migración
quedan bastante tiempo entonces qué
llevó yo preguntar y a más bien Qué
llevó a estos migrantes a protestar y a
exigir una resolución porque el proceso
de solicitud de asilo en Estados Unidos
no fluye en México las conducciones
tampoco están fluyendo Entonces esta ira
de los migrantes pues genera este
estallido al ser informados de que van a
ser deportados desde el principio creo
que hay muchas omisiones en el proceso
de establecer a los migrantes de ver si
pasan si solicitan Cuál es el
procedimiento para que soliciten este
asilo político en Estados Unidos Perdón
así lo humanitario en Estados Unidos y
entonces en este procedimiento pues está
generando un hervidero entonces sobre la
mesa está la protesta y la violación a
derechos humanos que incluye haberlos
encerrado y dejarlos en celdas claro eso
me lleva a preguntarle illian sobre las
condiciones ha habido reiteradas
denuncias a los a lo largo de los años
sobre las condiciones que tienen que
padecer los migrantes allí en México
mientras se esperan estos procesos de
aceptación de asilo en México o de
aceptación de asilo en Estados Unidos si
se
Proponen como candidatos para este
programa de quédate en México que es
como como usted decía pues para quedarse
allí en México y de una forma legal y
comenzar a rehacer sus vidas allí en la
República Mexicana y no no entrar a
Estados Unidos como son las condiciones
Hay muchísimas críticas al gobierno
mexicano precisamente por esto también
Sí por supuesto y dentro de la bancada
oficialista como de la oposición
principalmente organizaciones civiles
han cuestionado las condiciones vimos
hace algunos años no sé si recuerde
Santiago en el sur del país albergues
que tenían pues condiciones pues ya
deplorables habían decenas de migrantes
la capacidad estaba rebasada Aunque sí
se les ha brindado el lo básico cuentan
con alimento y el proceso asesoría legal
jurídica también se les brinda Pues
también el hacinamiento que ya se está
viviendo en esos albergues pues no es el
óptimo para que puedan estar ahí más de
un mes dos meses hay casos en los que
han permanecido hasta dos años y
entonces ahí vemos niños hay bebés
también hay mucho recurso que se está
invirtiendo en algunos de estos
albergues para proporcionar asesoría hay
ongs que se han acercado esta es la
parte muy buena también que hay que
destacar hay ongs que se están acercando
que asesoran principalmente a las
mujeres a los niños que son los que
pueden tener esta agilización del
proceso para que puedan llevar su
solicitud tanto en Estados Unidos como
mencionas aquí en México pero sí se ha
cuestionado mucho
la violencia que se ha vivido en muchos
de esos centros como lo vimos en el sur
cuando había enfrentamientos y también
hay que cuestionar en esta parte cuando
se juntan tantas emociones en migrantes
que buscan una nueva o mejor condición
de vida necesitamos personal capacitado
que pueda lidiar con estas emociones y
este juego y desesperación porque
entonces han enviado a guardias
nacionales a oficiales de seguridad que
no están capacitados para tratar la
parte emocional de personas que buscan
una mejor condición de vida y es cuando
hemos visto estos enfrentamientos Claro
porque un agente de seguridad está
adiestrado para ello para garantizar
seguridad no para procesos legales No
eso que dice illion de las emociones es
muy importante porque recordemos que
muchas de estas personas vienen de hacer
travesías sumamente exigentes de vivir
episodios sumamente fuertes y
traumáticos sobre todo aquellos que
vienen desde Suramérica y atraviesan el
tapón del Darién que es un punto
sumamente complicado que cobra la vida
de cientos de personas en esa travesía
desde Colombia hasta Panamá no todos
ellos llegan de países como Guatemala
Honduras que son países bueno el caso de
Guatemala pues tiene frontera común con
México y la travesía es un poco más
corta para otros incluso comienza del
otro lado del Atlántico en las costas
africanas cuando tratan de llegar hasta
las costas de Suramérica y empiezan su
travesía para llegar a Estados Unidos Y
lean esto me lleva a preguntarle sobre
esa política de quédate en México qué
tan exitosa ha sido qué percepción hay
allí entre pues entre ustedes los
comunicadores los periodistas sobre esta
política que resultó tó siendo muy
atractiva en su momento porque
latinoamérica habitualmente no es un
país que sirva para recibir migrantes
normalmente
son países que son emisores de migrantes
hacia Estados Unidos en su mayoría pero
ahora México está ofreciendo unas
condiciones para que la gente Pues
desista de realizar su sueño americano
digámoslo así y opte por un podemos
llamarlo un sueño mexicano
Así es Mira desde la perspectiva
periodística yo te puedo decir que sí ha
habido mucho movimiento en este programa
en quédate en México son ya pues ya años
meses de ese procedimiento durante la
administración de Donald Trump se envió
a más de 71 mil solicitantes de asilo a
esperar en México en este proceso en
este tiempo no ha habido un cambio en la
política aunque sea establecido un
estire y afloje como le decimos aquí en
México y las autoridades han negociado
ya en tiempos de Joe biden también se ha
negociado esta parte de Cuántos aceptara
Cuántos vamos a regularizar y en México
muchos como y aquí hago este acotamiento
Porque muchos que pasan esa travesía a
la hora de querer llegar a Estados
Unidos al ver tantos obstáculos
evidentemente deciden quedarse en México
el quedarse en México la solicitud
Aunque pareciera o que la hacen ver como
algo sencillo no lo ha sido Entonces en
este proceso en el camino por también
quedarse en México miles de personas lo
han logrado hemos visto principalmente
se han asentado en la Ciudad de México
en este trayecto en el sur del país han
enfrentado muchísimo
discriminación muchísimos actos de
violencia también los migrantes y en el
norte del país pues al estar ya más
cerca de lo que ellos buscaban como el
sueño americano pues ya dejan detrás
este proceso desde que ingresan a México
se les da asesoría y apoyo para que sea
como la opción no este en este acuerdo
que se hizo entre ambas naciones Pues
que se queden aquí no pero ya Mientras
más se acercan a Estados Unidos pues
evidentemente más el deseo de solicitar
para Estados Unidos Entonces yo sí
agregaría que en todo este trayecto pues
también ha habido muchos eh huecos
muchos huecos tanto informativos como
políticos ilegales de De qué está
pasando con esos migrantes si hemos
visto caravanas caravanas que pasan pero
de de la entrada a México por el sur del
país hasta el norte de este hemos visto
denuncias de desapariciones denuncias de
violación a derechos humanos este
violencia física denuncias también de
maltrato por parte de autoridades de
organizaciones y demás Entonces el
programa quédate en México tiene mucho
en juego tanto para Estados Unidos como
para México porque en algún momento se
va a hacer un balance Santiago de todos
de todas todas estas cifras Entonces ya
tardaron en hacer ese corte y el balance
y el balance pues puede tener las dos
caras de la moneda para ir cerrando este
tema ella Quiero preguntarle por la
justicia mexicana sobre este caso este
incendio en este centro de detención de
migrantes ya como como usted nos decía
hay algunas detenciones para rendir unas
primeras versiones sobre los hechos
personas que estaban involucradas en la
seguridad de ese centro de detención
Pero qué tanto podemos creer en la
justicia mexicana y lo digo bajo el
argumento de las altas tasas de
impunidad que hay no solamente de este
tipo de investigaciones sino de otro
tipo de de hechos como asesinatos o
crímenes que están relacionados con el
narcotráfico la impunidad reina en
México en este tipo de temas bueno en
general en América Latina la justicia es
bastante débil
por supuesto es una cuestión regional
pero tienes en gran medida razón en
México pues desgraciadamente sí ha
habido demasiada impunidad y se quedan
en el trayecto mientras no existe
presión no hay en hay casos muy locales
en los que hemos visto resultados Pero
porque la presión aumenta como algunas
desapariciones en Casos de adolescentes
desaparecidas ha habido cierran avenidas
cierran exigen la justicia bloquean
calles y es cuando vemos una solución
Lamentablemente Así es como ha ido
funcionando en México la justicia
recientemente no hablo de años pasados
pero recientemente es eso con la presión
en el caso de los incendios del incendio
en el centro de detención del imm Pues
sí creo que la presión va a tener mucho
que ver ahorita El Seis de el presidente
López Obrador informó de seis detenidos
también con la fiscal general pero este
las víctimas mortales eran originarias
de Guatemala El Salvador Venezuela
Honduras y Colombia tenemos ahí a varios
países que pueden hacer presión
Considero que sí si no sube esta presión
no se exige esa justicia podríamos ver
otro caso de impunidad pero sí países y
exigen esa solución Podría tener y debe
tener porque ya involucró también una
organización internacionales No por
ahora el único país que ha dado una
respuesta rápida ha sido Guatemala
justamente porque la gran mayoría de los
fallecidos Lamentablemente son
nacionales de ese país centroamericano
illiam vamos a dejar el tema de México
hasta ahí porque tenemos otros temas
para desarrollar en nuestra agenda del
programa pero incorporamos también a
nuestra conversación a Andrea Aguilar
ella es editor internacional de
televisión Nacional de chile tvn que se
conecta desde la ciudad de Santiago
Andrea bienvenidas un gusto para
nosotros tenerla en el programa Y qué
tal termina usted su semana allí en
Santiago
Santiago cómo estás y para mí es un
gusto También participar en el programa
bueno una semana que para yo creo
cualquier editor internacional ha estado
movida especialmente después de lo que
pasó ayer con el expresidente Donald
Trump Así que ha sido que bueno una
semana pasada por toda cantidad de de
emociones de coberturas
recordemos también que había un tiroteo
del al principio de la semana Entonces
toda una cantidad de de noticias digamos
internacionales bien impresionantes y
bueno Obviamente todos enfocados en esos
momentos En cuáles van a ser las digamos
las perspectivas o las conclusiones de
lo que va a llegar a ser el caso del
expresidente en Estados Unidos
justamente ese tema quiero que hablemos
Andrea porque esta semana pues hubo
muchos anuncios importantes para un
mandatario que está en oficio y para un
expresidente al ex presidente Trump era
que estaba mencionando Andrea hablamos
del presidente de Ecuador Guillermo
lasso quien rechazó las acusaciones que
llevaron a que deba enfrentarse a un
juicio político lazo Indicó que dará la
ante el país pero eso sí se declaró
Inocente de dichas acusaciones entre
tanto en Estados Unidos y Esto va en
línea con lo que mencionaba Andrea el
expresidente Donald Trump será imputado
penalmente por el pago de sobornos a la
actriz de cine para adultos stormy
Daniels a cambio de su silencio aunque
también el proceso habla de
falsificación de documentos por parte de
la defensa también esto pues pasará su
factura en términos judiciales lo
paradójico de todo esto es que Trump no
va a responder ante la justicia porque
darse con documentos oficiales que
guardaban su casa de mar al lago en la
Florida tampoco por la insurrección del
Capitolio en la ciudad de Washington y
tampoco por la desinformación que él
provocaba a través de las redes sociales
suena muy paradójico le doy la palabra
Andrea en Chile su opinión sobre sobre
este tema lo paradójico que resulta ver
a Trump acusado sentado en el banquillo
por pago de sobornos a una actriz de
cine para adultos
realmente es bien impresionante eso
Santiago Porque además recordemos que es
un caso que viene desde hace 17 años
atrás y que recién empezaba a hacer
noticia en el año 2016 bueno en el año
2018 ya empieza obviamente toda la
acusación formal Pero tú lo mencionabas
realmente es bien complejo entender
porque un expresidente de Estados Unidos
no rinde cuentas ante la justicia por
tema de evasión de impuestos por las los
negocios de su familia por lo que fue el
asalto el Capitolio también pero termina
rindiendo cuentas por algo que
finalmente no es él directamente
involucrado sino se sabe que el pago Se
habría hecho
el abogado y realmente da para mucho que
pensar de Cómo funciona la justicia en
este país y también que recordemos
además estamos en un año previo a lo que
va a ser toda la temporada de elecciones
y parece que no sé si ustedes han
escuchado a nosotros en medios de
Estados Unidos pero le dicen como dos
teflón literalmente todas las opiniones
todas las los procesos judiciales le le
resbalan a Donald Trump porque
finalmente él terminaba pudiendo eh
capitalizar lo que es el tema en este
caso este pago de esta actriz porno y
que finalmente No termina siendo más que
como un un Corrillo o
generalmente
la justicia y vamos a ver Obviamente el
próximo martes si finalmente pusieron
enfrentar cargos en Estados Unidos
realmente es pero habla también de En
qué punto está la posición Estados
Unidos hoy le preguntaban de hecho a
bidens que pensaba él él decía que no
iba a hacer ningún tipo de comentarios
Entonces es realmente bien complicado
Cómo se se está viendo en estos momentos
y también cómo se va a ver De cara a lo
que van a hacer las elecciones del
próximo año
en México en Ciudad de México creo que
me suena mucho algo que dice Andrea y es
el presidente Trump el expresidente
Trump Resulta ser un personaje sumamente
hábil en el manejo de las crisis en el
manejo de los medios de comunicación yo
creo que sería el ejemplo perfecto de
este dicho que dice que la crisis está
la oportunidad Pese a que está en medio
de esta tormenta judicial él logra
capitalizarlo a su favor cómo lo ve
usted illiam Por supuesto y no es la
primera vez como menciona Andrea ha
sabido utilizar esto y bajo su discurso
de que se trata de una cacería de brujas
en su contra desde que trataron de
imputarlo y se fue a juicio por la
cuestión del Capitolio pues ha sabido
sacar raja política le decimos en México
de esta situación y ha sabido
capitalizar porque aunque sí de santis
el gobernador de Florida le está dando
batalla incluso unas encuestas pues lo
colocan por arriba de Trump en la
intención de Voto y por arriba también
de Joe biden tenemos solo a de santis
entonces Trump sabe que ahorita tiene
una nueva oportunidad de regresar a la
casa blanca y esta haciendo como Comenta
Andrea pues una suerte de crisis no
Entonces
él desde el discurso desde el discurso
en el que su abogada y abogados dicen
que el martes por voluntad propia se
presentará ante el Jurado ahí el
tribunal en Manhattan ya está
Aprovechando recordemos que es un
empresario y la visión de un empresario
y un político de carrera es muy distinta
él como empresario sabe hacer eso
sacarle provecho a la oportunidad
Entonces el presentarse de manera
voluntaria le dará un beneficio
políticamente hablando y también en
materia electoral no tuvo la
convocatoria que él esperaba él llamó
Cuando filtraron esto él llamó a
protestar él llamó a sus seguidores a
protestar y salir a las calles y en los
días siguientes en los que se esperaba
la votación y El veredicto ahí en en
este tribunal pues al final no hubo el
quórum que le esperaba Ayer no hubo
protestas entonces Sí estamos viendo que
él ha sabido matizar la situación ha
sabido aprovecharla acusar una
persecución y un obstáculo
electoralmente hablando pero también
estamos viendo la pérdida de Seguidores
que está teniendo si hubiera sido el
donaldrían llenas las calles sería un
escenario muy diferente Andrea aquí en
los dos escenarios tanto en Estados
Unidos como en Ecuador se habla de una
posible persecución política ustedes lo
ven así claro que son dos escenarios
distintos estamos hablando de un
expresidente un presidente en oficio que
se enfrenta a un juicio político de otro
simplemente la justicia ordinaria
hay aquí persecución ustedes notan
indicios de persecución como dice Andrea
de Cara a esos comicios presidenciales
en Estados Unidos sobre todo
Yo creo que es bien complicado hablar de
persecución
dos escenarios completamente distintos
pero el caso de
lo cual no hay pruebas cuando él ni
siquiera había asumido su cargo como
presidente y en el caso de Donald Trump
estamos hablando de lo que también pasó
antes de que él fuera
presidente ambos obviamente dicen eso es
una persecución política en el caso de
Trump recordemos ha sido esa su bandera
de campaña durante su vida política su
corta vida política siempre ha dicho
prácticamente que eh lo está
persiguiendo de hecho en estos momentos
todavía no ha reconocido la victoria de
Joe biden en sus comunicados a través de
su red social Él sigue insistiendo en
que él fue el ganador de las elecciones
Yo he sido el mejor presidente y también
lo que decía capitalizado completamente
la carta que él siempre juega y que
seguramente le va muchos réditos de Cara
a lo que van a hacer las elecciones en
2024 porque gran parte de su electorado
sigue creyendo que a él le robaron las
elecciones en el 2020 y finalmente esto
y todo este show mediático que
seguramente vamos a tener el martes y
que de hecho hay muchos medios en
Estados Unidos que decían que él es un
hombre al que le gusta esto él sabe
manejar el negocio Incluso le había
preguntado a sus hijos a sus cercanos a
qué cámara miro cómo lo hago debería o
no desfilar debería uno Mostrarme todo
este tipo y aparte Estados Unidos
países donde el show vende Y seguramente
te van a obtener la imagen del avión
presidencial de Trump saliendo desde
Mara lago hasta el tribunal de Manhattan
lo que mencionaba También es importante
él no tiene seguramente la misma fuerza
en las calles que tuvo en lo que pasó en
el asalto al Capitolio o los mítines
enormes que vimos cuando él era el
candidato presidencial a las elecciones
de 2020 seguramente ha perdido algo de
apoyo popular al menos en las calles
pero sí vas a tener todo ese hecho
mediático y vamos a tener que ver y que
analizar qué va a pasar y ver si es
finalmente una persecución o no que yo
entiendo que el tiempo el término de
persecución igual es bien politizado en
el caso tanto de lazo como de Trump y
creo que vamos en el en el fondo están
tratando como de descubrir un poco el
bulto
decimos acá frente a las penales que
tiene y en decir que esto no es mi culpa
sino por culpa del partido opositor de
turno el caso de los demócratas en el
caso de lazo de la izquierda ecuatoriana
de que solo es mi culpa sino Son ellos
los que no me quieren dejar gobernar o
Son ellos los que no me quieren dejar
presentar como candidato
claro
interpretar como de digamos judicial que
eso no lo vemos solamente en esos dos
casos tenemos referentes en Argentina
tenemos referentes en Colombia en
cualquier parte de América Latina
podemos encontrar ese tipo de cajas Así
que yo creo que la comparación pero no
hablaría como tal como de persecución
como un término en el que podamos
analizar si hay o no Claro
que justamente ha dicho Trump en sus
declaraciones en las últimas horas por
eso por eso lo cito hay que decir
haciendo referencia a lo que menciona
Andrea En su comentario que claramente
Pues todo esto tiene que tener show
Donald Trump no da una puntada sin dedal
Como dice el dicho hoy estoy lleno de
refranes en el programa de hoy nunca me
pasa pero hoy sí y Tal parece que todo
está fríamente calculado de cómo debe
ser manejada su posición su figura su
Cómo se muestra él ante los medios y
ante los estadounidenses porque hay que
decirlo Estados Unidos también está
saliendo de esta crisis económica en
donde todo esto Pues también le da
ratings a los medios de comunicación la
gente descarga información a través de
las redes y también pues compran diarios
en las calles para enterarse de qué es
lo que está pasando esto también se
vuelve un círculo vicioso a nivel
económico para ir cerrando este tema
quiero hablar del caso de Ecuador que
también es muy importante lo que va a
suceder allí le pregunto a Ian algunos
analistas mencionan que hay temor en
América Latina que Ecuador comience a
vivir un proceso digamos lo de
peruanización de la situación política y
es que el gobierno o se ve afectado por
esto está gran separación que hay entre
los dos extremos políticos en una
polarización inmensa y haya una no
persecución pero sí una seguidilla de
presidentes que entran y salen del
gobierno a raíz de todos estos juicios
políticos que empiezan a fomentarse
desde un lado del otro a través de los
parlamentos
Ecuador tiene muchísimos problemas a
nivel interno Pero cómo lo ve usted
illiam
sí esos problemas internos que mencionas
Santiago tienen mucho que ver para
determinar lo que va a venir en materia
política en Ecuador vienen de muchas
crisis en materia de seguridad por
ejemplo en los motines que se han dado
en las cárceles también ya no están
dejando tranquilos tranquila la
población
en cuestión política hay algo que
debemos destacar en contraste con otros
procesos que se están viviendo como el
que mencionábamos en Estados Unidos en
el de Ecuador si hay una oposición que
está tomando nuevos eslabones que está
tomando fuerza bajo el mando por así
llamarlo de Rafael Correa tenemos mucho
eco no La asambleísta Viviana veloz que
fue la que metió el pedido de juicio
político contra laso también está
haciendo eco entre la población es muy
importante en todos los países en
escenario político Quién representa ese
liderazgo de oposición y en el caso de
Ecuador sí creo que también si Correa
sabe capitalizar esta situación el
hartazgo de la población el har que se
está viviendo también no solo en Ecuador
en el mundo entero por la cuestión
económica que afectó a partir de la
pandemia de Coby 19 pero si esa
oposición sabe capitalizar los
desaciertos en materia política en
materia de seguridad en materia
económica van a poder hacer una presión
unánime contra el gobierno lo que sí
aunque el asambleísta ve los comenta que
hay pruebas para acusar de malversación
de fondos a lazo hay que esperar a ver
en los próximos días dicen que lo van a
presentar la próxima semana ver esas
pruebas y de ahí determinar tanto en
cuestión mediática pero sí
principalmente en cuestión política creo
y me atrevería a decir que dependiendo
de estas pruebas van a saber si le dan
el golpe que quieren dar por parte de la
oposición contra lazo o se pierde y
quedan ese intento de estar descontento
con un presidente y presionarlo para su
salida no un juicio político que como
bien dice a un cambio y un cambio no me
arriesgaría a decir que se trate de un
cambio de presidentes pero sí uno en el
que debiliten bastante a la izquierda de
ese país bueno Ecuador Apenas está
empezando los Estados Unidos están en
desarrollo ya veremos qué sucede a lo
largo de los próximos días vamos a pasar
a nuestro siguiente tema Ya vamos
llegando al bloque final del programa en
otro escenario completamente diferente
vamos a hablar de esa atención entre
Rusia y Estados Unidos porque Moscú
arrestó al corresponsal del The Wall
Street journal y van gercovich que fue
arrestado por el servicio Federal de
seguridad por presunto espionaje y fue
detenido Entonces por un mes y 29 días
de manera provisional mientras avanza la
investigación
no admitió su culpabilidad en otro
escenario también hay que hablar en
Rusia porque nuevamente fue detenido
alexioff él es el ciudadano Ruso padre
de esta menor de edad que cuya imagen le
dio la vuelta del mundo que fue enviada
a un orfanato por haber hecho en clase
un dibujo en contra de la guerra en
Ucrania
mosca lioff escapó de su arresto
domiciliario porque su hija fue enviada
a un orfanato y él fue enviado a prisión
a resto domiciliario condenado por dos
años y se escapó Fue capturado entonces
nuevamente en Minsk que es la capital de
velarus un país vecino de Rusia que como
sabemos Pues también está en cierta
forma involucrado en este conflicto
en Ucrania comienzo entonces dándole la
palabra a Andrea la sensación que deja
esta este arresto de este periodista hay
muchísimos matices se habla de
de una forma de censura de simplemente
fomentar la atención con Washington es
un periodista que ya llevaba seis años
viviendo en Rusia es decir los servicios
de seguridad podían haber hecho
seguimiento de su actividad a lo largo
del tiempo y podían haber tomado medidas
hace mucho tiempo atrás Andrea sus
impresiones
un punto importante y es que él es un
periodista que estaba investigando la
industria militar en Rusia entonces como
que eso se ha calificado de espionaje
nos habla del fenómeno de lo que es
prácticamente la criminalización de
informar en Moscú y de eso tenemos que
empezar a hablar desde que parte
obviamente la guerra que se tienen que
ir prácticamente todos los periodistas
de medios occidentales de Moscú o que
tienen que empezar a informar con más
cuidado empiezan a ser perseguidos y lo
que estamos viendo justamente con este
caso el periodista es prácticamente
criminalizar el hecho de informar ya el
mismo periódico el Wester journal ha
dicho que no tiene nada que ver que no
hay una labor de espionaje Y si a eso le
sumamos algo tan tan absurdo si lo
podemos calificar de de eso eh Como que
se separe aún ahí a una niña de 13 años
del papá que es un padre soltero al cual
manda no detienen ayer en Bielorrusia y
ella está prácticamente en un orfanato
por hacer un dibujo que no sé si ustedes
lo vieron pero es un dibujo en donde hay
Bueno una una mamá con unos niños en
donde están evitando Están en contra de
los
soldadores
[Música]
de Gloria Ucrania y lo que hace el
contexto que dicen los medios rusos es
que el papá estarían como manipulando
ideológicamente a la niña porque lo que
se le había pedido en clase a esa niña
era que hiciera un dibujo eh digamos
apoyando a las fuerzas militares
entonces creo que también Ambos casos
nos hablan de El hecho de lo mucho que
le molesta al gobierno de Vladimir la
disidencia que lo hemos visto en todos
los casos no hay que ir muy lejos para
encontrarnos con escenarios como el de
navaldi
persona cualquier opositor
va a ser silenciada
Sí bueno yo separaría ambos casos pero
sí en el primero en la detención del
periodista de Wall Street journal sí
creo que hay una cuestión importante se
da en el marco de las declaraciones
amenazantes y en el amago de usar armas
nucleares por qué lo menciono porque
recientemente pues la fuerza de Rusia en
Ucrania Se ha perdido las batallas se
concentran en una sola ciudad se perdió
lo que los objetivos que esperaba tener
a corto plazo Vladimir Putin no se han
visto y entonces en esta pérdida de
fuerza está buscando nuevas estrategias
se habla de una contraofensiva pero
empezó a dar ese discurso de materia
nuclear se sumaron otros países le
proporcionó también armamento Irán vino
otra polémica entonces Estados Unidos se
pronunció Y en este estira y afloje
entre Estados Unidos y Rusia pues se
mencionó también la capacidad de
responder por parte de Estados Unidos a
estas amenazas siempre y cuando no
vulneren a su territorio a sus fuerzas
etcétera sí creo que es importante que
se dé esta detención y se acuse a un
periodista de espionaje en materia
militar justamente después de tantos
años no la última vez que Rusia detuvo a
un periodista por espionaje fue en 1986
no habíamos visto esta tensión en ambas
naciones en materia periodística hasta
ahorita y aunque hubo otros casos de
opositores que tocaron base en Estados
Unidos pues no se ve acusado
directamente por parte del servicio de
inteligencia ruso de esta situación
Entonces sí creo que el telón de fondo
de esta presión viene siendo discurso
nuclear que se está calentando en todo
el mundo eh No únicamente en Rusia Se
está calentando todo el mundo la otan
informó del aumento poco más de uno por
ciento del armamento nuclear en el mundo
entonces hablamos de un contexto muy
caliente yo le llamaría Santiago illiam
Qué temas están bajo la lupa
rápidamente muy puntual por favor
eventual procedimiento el próximo martes
y por supuesto en una semana tan
especial las la salud del Papa Francisco
que ya fue dado de alta y visitó algunos
enfermos pero en la lupa sobre la
Iglesia Católica estará puesta esta
semana y sin duda Pues también la
adhesión de Finlandia a la otan claro y
Andrea sus temas
Bueno yo creo que son los mismos de los
de cualquier editor internacional la
próxima semana por el lado del martes
obviamente ver qué va a pasar con el
expresidente Donald Trump ver cómo va a
ser la salud del Papa durante esta
semana Aunque hoy lo vimos mucho más
recuperado de lo de la audiencia del
miércoles y seguramente también seguir
en la pista lo que está sucediendo en
Ucrania recordemos además que Finlandia
se va a poder unir a la otan Así que
también hay que estar bien atentos a que
pueda efectuar o que pueda hacer
consecuencia pueda tener esta adhesión
de Finlandia Y qué respuesta va a tener
finalmente de Rusia el hecho de que este
país se sume también a la otan creo que
sería como unas tres líneas para la
próxima semana y yo añadiría a esa lupa
añadiría ese cambio de política exterior
que ha anunciado Rusia al final de esta
semana que le da un nuevo enfoque
antioxidante anti Estados Unidos hay que
ver que reacciones genera esto Andrea
Muchísimas gracias por estar con
nosotros les recuerdo que la producción
del programa estuvo a cargo de Laura
garzón y de Jennifer Guevara también la
producción de invitados estuvo a cargo
de Tania Herrera Muchas gracias Pueden
seguir dejando los comentarios a través
de las redes sociales sigan con nosotros
[Música]